logia devil fruits allow its users to
actually transform their entire body
into a specific natural element the
smoke smoke fruit was eaten by smoker
the sand sand fruit was eaten by
crocodile the flame flame fruit was
first eaten by Ace and then by Sabo the
rumble Rumble fruit was eaten by an l
and it allows him to become lightning
the ice ice fruit was eaten by kuzan the
dark dark fruit was eaten by Blackbeard
the glint glint fruit was eaten by
Borsalino and it allows him to become
light the magmag fruit was eaten by
sakazuki and it allows him to become
magma the swamp swamp fruit was eaten by
caribou and it allows him to become a
living swamp the gas gas fruit was eaten
by Caesar Clown the snow snow fruit was
eaten by Monet and finally the woods
Woods fruit was eaten by Green Bull and
it allows him to become a living Forest